Regardless of the method used,
modern botnets usually have one or
two goals in mind, illegal profits or
political activism.
Here are some examples of attacks and
frauds by botnets.
Spam, almost all spams
are sent by botnets.
All Distributed Denial
of Service Attacks or
DDOS are now launched by botnets.
Clickfrauds, phishing and
pharming, key logging.
Almost all bot malware is loaded
via key logging capabilities.
Password cracking,
using the aggregated computational of
power of a botnet to crack password.
Use of botnet to run anonymization
protocols and route traffic
in order to hide communications
by criminals and terrorists.
Use the bots in a botnet to coordinate,
in order to cheat in online games and
polls.
And the list goes on.